hey everyone it's michaelos from
orderflows oncom and you I wanted to
create this short video for you in case
you wanted to learn orderflow trading
but you don't know where to start okay
one of the problems with trading you
know in any type of analysis is you know
there's not a lot of good analysis out
there so you know I created this course
it's called the orderflow trading course
and what it is it's a series of 20
recordings it's actually about 16 15 16
hours originally I wanted to create it
to be about uh 8 hours so you can get
through it on a Saturday but you know
once I started putting pen to paper and
recording videos you know I realized you
know 8 hours isn't going to really cover
as much as I would like so it ended up
being double so you know you can do it
on a weekend if you like to cram you
know Netflix type weekend where you
watch a whole series in one weekend or
you know you spend one hour a day doing
it you can get through it in about two
weeks and you know the reason I created
this you know I've been trading with
orderflow for most of my career and you
know these are the teachings and my
method of trading you know based on the
orderflow strategies I've developed over
20 years of trading and you know I don't
use moving averages oscillators or bands
to back my trading decisions you know I
don't combine them with orderflow
trading and teaching which you know a
lot of people do they'll have vwap and
say oh you get the two standard
deviations you sell it well what happens
when you go to three deviations four
deviations it happens a lot more than
people care to
realize and you know I don't necessarily
teach any of the preset order flow
trading methods that circulate for free
over the Internet a lot of these people
that teach this stuff you know never
traded on the inside never traded as a
institutional Trader you know people
that know me you can see my bio on my
website orderflows decom you know I've
spent 20 years trading on the
institutional level I spent eight years
at JP Morgan I mean who spends you know
if if you've been in this business long
enough you know that working at a bank
if you're a Trader you only spend two
three years there till you move on and
get a better job you know but i' I
reached you know i' I'll say I reached
the highest level I could go you know JP
Morgan is a pretty respectable Bank how
much higher am I going to get but you
know I lasted 8 years there you know
even before that I was with Cargill
before that I was with CER Bank the big
German Bank although German banks now
are are having a lot of problems and you
know before that EDF man you know these
are Big solid trading companies you know
I I didn't just take a course on you
know spend pay someone $3,000 to teach
me how to trade and then come out and
put myself as an expert you know I have
real life trading experience trading
experience you know that's gained
working at these
companies and you know and what I'm
trying to do is you know I'm trying to
get that information out to out to the
public because you know there is a lot
of bad information out there on the
market unfortunately it's true but you
know
people don't know where to start and you
know if you start learning and you
learning the wrong way then you're
better off not learning it at all okay
so what is the orderflow trading course
well again like I I said it's a 20
lesson course that I created and I I
really try to cover everything possible
in orderflow this is this is the website
okay so lesson one introduction to
orderflow lesson two orderflow software
and data feeds now again whether you
have software whether you have my own
software or whether you know you have
someone else's software that you pay
thousands of dollars for it doesn't
matter you know orderflow there's only
certain there's only so many ways you
can put orderflow into a chart and that
comes out as a footprint
chart so whether you use mine or not it
doesn't matter you know the same
Concepts apply to all volume footprint
charts you know in lesson two I
discussed the different software out
there and the different data feeds
lesson three how to read the order flow
chart Lesson Four the orderflow
orderflow terms lesson five who are the
market participants you have to
understand who you're trading against
lesson six different types of trading
happening in the market lesson seven
best markets to trade orderflow lesson
eight understanding marke IM balance
lesson n why the point of control is
significant lesson 10 the importance of
Delta is very
important lesson 11 orderflow price
rejection Lesson 12 orderflow support
and resistance levels lesson 13
understanding order flow fair prices and
absorption lesson 14 reading the market
with order flow lesson 15 order flow
trade setups I mean once you know how to
read order flow you should have some
setups that you can read rely on Lesson
16 orderflow reversal setups lesson 17
order flow continuation setups lesson 18
integrating orderflow analysis with
traditional technical analysis now I
understand you know everyone's going to
have their own way of trading I can't go
out there and teach you my way of
trading expect you to trade 100% Like Me
Maybe you have your own way of trading
and you want to add order flow to it and
you know in lesson 18 I I show you how
you can use orderflow with other forms
of technical analysis so hopefully you
know if if there's a way that's not
covered in there you can figure it out
for yourself and apply the order flow
with your own way of technical analysis
lesson 19 is testing yourself with
practice charts lesson 19 is the long
lesson it's about 2 hours most of these
are anywhere between 40 minutes and 1
hour lesson 20 is
conclusion now also the course downloads
there there's a bunch of downloads you
can I I wrote a book on orderflow
trading you can download it here right
here orderflow trading orderflow guide
it's 150
pages okay so you know the downloads you
can download all the courses uh just
click on their download these are all
the PDFs for the
courses this is the orderflow trading
guide down here you just click on you
know whichever one you want to download
and you can download the entire um you
know the the entire 20 courses so you
can go along and you know print it up or
refer to it at any time rather than just
the video and you know if you want to
watch you know video you you go through
a lesson you just click on the lesson
you want to watch you can you know
expand them you click on this to expand
it
okay it's a little bigger than the
screen uh the part that I'm recording
but you know you can U you see this
lesson's 22 minutes um you know
different lessons you know different
lengths of
time now this one's 45 minutes so you
know again I I really made this a
beginning to end course on trading with
orderflow because you know I realized
there's a lot of bad information out
there you know and a lot of information
being put out by people that quite
honestly don't have the experience to to
teach orderflow I mean you know when
you're talking about trading right you
should have someone that's actually
traded you know at either you know
institutional level or professional
level rather than someone's just talking
about Theory you know or maybe they just
traded their their small account for
themselves and you know there's a big
difference when you're trading an
account with $10,000 in it for a year as
opposed to trading you know I I don't
want to say how big the account is but
you know trading at an Institutional
level trading thousands of lots you know
a week I want say thousand lots a day
but you know there's days where you know
I've literally
traded 50,000 contracts easily
so you know I I understand order flow I
understand you know what causes the
market to move when an order hits the
market you know I why do I know because
I did it you know I was there I was the
one causing the market to move often and
I'm not saying I was trying to
manipulate the market not at all you
know I would know that I have to buy
2,000 e- minis at 4 in the morning and I
know what impact that's going to have on
the market so I got to finesse it in you
know whether I got to buy it up through
a few price levels or whether I think I
can work it or whether I see some depth
in the market that I can lean against
you know there's all these little
different intricacies that unless you've
actually done it you're not going to
understand it so you know who do you
want to learn from someone that's
learned and did it in real life for
their entire trading career or somebody
that's just done it for a year maybe
took a course on trading with order flow
from somebody or maybe somebody that
just sort of thinks I I figured it out
myself you know that's not experience
you know I have the experience and
that's what I'm trying to give to you in
this trading course so again you know if
you're interested in this course go down
to the description there's a link in the
description that you can go and sign up
for this course you know unfortunately
it does cost money I started giving away
some of the stuff for free then I I
realized people were were taking my
ideas and coding it up and selling it as
their own you they're calling it you
know this orderflow algo you know it was
just one of my simple ideas in orderflow
so you know get it from the originator
rather than
paying you know hundreds or even
thousands of dollars for some some of
these um ways of trading with
orderflow again you know it just you
know one of the reasons why I created
this course is there's just a lot of bad
information out there so again go to the
description you could find out more
there's a link to my website and a link
to a page that really you know also
describes what the course is about so
thank you for watching this video and I
hope to see you on the inside
bye-bye